plenty of excitement on TV tonight
because starting with a new star to
unmask on this season's breakout reality
TV yet
[Applause]
robot poodle came to play only we can
show you this sneak peek from tonight's
episode of the masked singer when six
new undercover celebs will belt out
their best onstage
[Music]
[Applause]
this is poodle this is actually one of
my favorite nine million viewers tuned
in to last week's premiere and et got an
exclusive tour during the show's taping
the clues are actually somehow put in by
the designers and the celebrities
themselves I mean at one point I thought
Kathy Griffin with the fuzzy hair but
are you Kathy hey also new tonight the
premiere of the Goldberg spit off school
let's go the nurses office at mood it's
not gonna work with me I'm the one who
invented it I have cramps et was
exclusively on the set of the comedy
which takes us from the 80s into the 90s
and now Barry's fiance Lainey is a
teacher at their old high school what I
like in school that was a regular school
year after everybody adjusted how do you
want us to wrap it up anything you want
us to do I know how to wrap it up oh
yeah Entertainment Tonight is the best
it resprayed I like them magical magic
thanks guys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]